given the current situation it's no
wonder people have turned to the
Internet to carry out routine tasks
whether office meetings school lectures
or even piano and violin lessons
something that's odd though is that
people aren't turning to classic Skype
or Cisco WebEx but rather zoom in in
fact for zoom first-time mobile app
users have gone 748 percent since March
2nd and throughout March over 200
million users were participating in
meetings every single day just two
months ago most of us had never even
heard about zoom so why is everyone
suddenly using zoom well starting off
zoom doesn't require attendees and
meetings to create an account like
virtually every other video conferencing
platform to join a meeting you simply
have to enter the meeting ID and toe
recently a password was not even
required furthermore if you're on a
computer you don't even have to install
any software you can literally just
click on a join meeting link from the
host and enter your name and your in
when companies and schools are trying to
get thousands of people to adopt a new
medium of communication ease of use is
critical and being able to avoid meeting
attendees from having to sign up or
install any software is a significant
advantage this is especially useful for
schools as they can avoid students from
using creating an account or installing
software as an excuse to not participate
but at the same time this is a clear
security risk as pretty much anyone can
join in on meetings companies that are
sharing sensitive information offer
calls are well aware of the security
risk and generally have reservations
before adopting zoom however for the
vast majority of users this is not much
of a concern
anyways as I doubt hackers are trying to
learn about Keynesian economics or
moment of inertia aside from being the
easiest video conferencing solution by
far
zoom also has many unique features that
users often love one of these unique
features is zoom rooms zoom rooms is a
simple
solution to set up a video conferencing
room but users far preferred to other
solutions citing an easily navigable you
I along with again ease-of-use
moving on for large institutions and
companies zoom is significantly cheaper
for twenty hours per month per host on
zoom you can get the business plan which
allows for meetings with up to three
hundred participants the relative plan
from WebEx cost twenty seven dollars per
month per host and also only allows for
two hundred participants this may not
seem like a big deal but when you're
purchasing thousands of subscriptions it
adds up quickly for instance let's take
a look at a large University like the
University of Texas at Austin this
university has over 50,000 students and
three thousand professors undergrad
lecturers here often have hundreds of
students beauty worth to buy twenty five
hundred business plans for their
professors zoom would cost fifty
thousand dollars a month while WebEx
would cost sixty seven thousand five
hundred a month a 35 percent increase
every single month furthermore
medium-sized institutions and companies
can often get away with the free version
of zoom as that itself supports up to
one hundred participants toe very
recently Skype and WebEx only supported
fifty years in their free version which
they both up to one hundred matching
zoom so generally not only is zoom
easier to use but also cheaper but how
is a small start-up able to handle all
of the logistics of hosting millions of
meetings per day and still afford to
beat out industry leaders in pricing
well it's not just beginner's luck or
unlimited funding from Jeff Bezos in
fact so far we've been comparing WebEx
and zoom as if they're competitors which
they are currently but what's ironic is
that both companies were built by the
same person Eric you won while Eric
didn't actually create WebEx but he was
the vice president of engineering at
WebEx and he joined the company just two
years after they started in 1997
eventually in 2007 WebEx would be sold
to Cisco for 3.2 billion dollars and
Eric would become the vice president
engineering at Cisco
however he describes our WebEx
development lagged after cisco bought
WebEx he says that WebEx simply stalled
and stopped pushing to offer the best
user experience possible disappointed in
the lack of progress for WebEx Eric and
forty engineers from Cisco quit in 2011
and start resume given their background
it's really no wonder why zoom is so
well built it was built by the same
people who built WebEx so all of the
technical portions of building a video
conferencing platform was a breeze their
main objective was to simply improve in
areas they taught WebEx was lacking and
this was his abuse new features and
pricing but just because they had the
best product didn't mean they instantly
caught on the video conferencing space
is extremely competitive and well
established as a result it was very
difficult to convert businesses who are
the main demographic to zoom companies
were simply used to systems they were
already using and reluctant to change
however after years of marketing and
growth the superior product did end up
appealing to many companies allowing a
zoom to slowly work their way up to
number two in the video conferencing
space only be it not by their older
brother WebEx as a pocket 2019 so zoom
was already a behemoth before the recent
situation but with the sudden explosion
of people looking for a video
conferencing solution the market quickly
expanded and the key ingredient for
zooms growth recently is that these
users have no bias towards any one
platform as they are new to all of them
so they flock towards the most
convenient video conferencing solution
on the market leading to zoom
essentially blowing up as they over
doubled in valuation from under 20
billion dollars at the end of 2019 to 46
billion dollars today if you guys
thought this via explained the sudden
rise of zoom well then make sure drop a
like and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one